back in the day you got up in front of a
bunch people they didn't know you were
care about you and it was like your
jokes at me I got I remember bombing and
[ __ ] Caroline yeah where the guy
threw a straw at me it's the only time I
was like I was gonna kick him in the
face yeah but but i but I kind of
deserved it because I was trying to be
funny and I was green and I yeah they
welded the owner said the club owner was
like he's green he's not ready for this
club that's my manager he was right yeah
he's right that's that's kind of the the
best part about starting out in a scene
like that it's like you're going up and
people like I don't know who the [ __ ]
you are
so do the job and you're second on
Penguin's oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I just remember
be I remember bombing at that same catch
rising star it was a Nichols Casino in
Providence
yeah and I headlined a weekend there and
I took such a beating and the feature
was doing like hey that mic stands big
black dick murderer murdering I mean I
thought these people were gonna [ __ ]
name their kids after this game and I
started calling Providence dumb Boston
because I got mad I was like [ __ ] you
you guys are just dumb Boston in their
bag is all mafia strong crazy I remember
two weekends to eat and [ __ ] like on
that kind of on that kind of tip if they
don't know you and in Providence Rhode
Island and then there was a Ticketmaster
write-up it's one of my first reviews
and they said the feature or the opener
was hilarious day at Sodor was just not
funny he checked his watch 20 times in
30 minutes and also [ __ ] you lady I did
45 I did my contractual obligation it
said he checked his watch 20 times in 30
minutes no one laughed it was sad I was
like play play pro football yeah Lana
Falcons they came in I was hotter than
zero and WCW I mean you know wrestling
face okay did I tell you like connect on
did I tell you story off air no I build
plays my brother in school then on the
Goldbergs and no problem he's he's 52
bills my age
from here to there oh he's he's he's but
when you look at his hand still like a
sting Vegas finger yeah and he's got the
biggest neck but he played pro football
he's a little bit athlete was a deal
island he's ridiculous d-tackle and well
there is and so we're the same as you
can see how much bigger he is
but either way he's very red very red so
but either way we do this thing where he
has to come through the line he has to
be a three-point stance and to stuntmen
come out of and he has to lay them out
and then he goes to me I'm gonna come at
you very that's a good classic he was
I'm gonna come at you I'm gonna die for
your head you have to duck out of the
way and I said this offset yeah he goes
I'm coming for you so make sure you duck
cuz for Bill there's bill has two gears
zero and [ __ ] let's [ __ ] go yeah
party so he goes I'm gonna I'm coming
for your head so make sure you [ __ ]
duck cuz for him he's gonna make it real
I these two stuntmen were big strong
martial arts guys yeah they were big
dude he was key was coming off that line
of 52 and hitting them so hard with his
elbows that the sound was so loud and
they were going they were flying yeah
III I said I stopped everything after
the third one because they were getting
hurt and I go hey we have to stop
I go bill you can't hit these guys this
hard I had to literally grill it yeah it
helped him out my larger point is there
another guys about the other girls hey
thanks Brian well dude they were getting
but my larger part is one of the guys
was a some kind of a special he was like
I mean yeah flash and I said to Bill I
go the way you were laying the money
goes hey dude I was a pro football
player yeah I don't give a [ __ ] what you
were if there is a difference between
pro football that that kind of level of
athletes yeah and and it all due respect
to anybody in the military really tough
guys but it is a little bit of a
different thing for sure like it so I
feel like you you would have been just
fine
doing a oh you were in the SEAL team is
that Pete Davidson is making his fans
sign an NDA prior to showing up to his
show and if they're in breach of this
NDA they can face up to a million
dollars
in a settlement agreement because the
spoil that he's worried they're gonna
leak his jokes online so what you have
to do is prior to the day of the show
you have to sign the NDA or you get a
full refund
that's very weird that is uh you see him
around New York and I've known Pete
since he was [ __ ] fifteen years old
I like these two he's sweet heart I
don't see him a lot anymore cuz I think
he's in like a different stratosphere of
like we're famous or I think he like jet
packs places and then can leave or he's
not like doing spots not really but I
just think this is so funny if I tried
doing this at like the Albany funnybone
Roma you guys got to sign an NDA in the
back so see your comedy but we're not
coming yeah I also write more jokes also
what are you doing but I thought did so
weird to me I think what it is is what
he's been is closely associated with so
many famous women now people are like if
he does a joke about Ariana Grande
they're like he said Ariana Grande's
pussy's tunafish in the rain bit yes
because we also remember you know just
to defend a little bit is when you know
Mac Miller died right yeah dated ariana
grande a lot of people blamed him for
which there's no that's ridicuious and
he and I guess yeah the owner of the
club keep someone in New York might be
care lines I forget where but he told
the owner goes hey please don't mention
anything about it was it was a stress
factory in Connecticut and it was my
journal in fact in New Jersey
yeah there's two there's one in
Connecticut he was doing the new one in
Connecticut he got he was I don't bring
up who I'm dating
and then Vinny the guy went out there
and did that yeah so he was like I
[ __ ] this and I guess he came out to
and Sohn yelled out Mac Miller something
like use like you know I'm not gonna
talk about though he said my friend he's
like I had a friend of mine died in my
apartment and he's like Mac Miller and
he's like get the [ __ ] out of here you
hit the dude out yeah I mean I think
when you're that like in the tabloids
that's why I think Eddie Murphy coming
back is gonna be [ __ ] weird
yeah how do you work [ __ ] out I don't
care for nine episodes but that's not a
full season right it is money to
episodes all season oh oh because they
were because it was only I was only
thirteen thirteen oh I see and it's
interesting and important because in my
twenty five years never had
but never happen dude do you first off
congrats student you remember when we're
yeah we're waiting to find out if you
got the pilot the pilot and they first
called you and said you did it
and you called me first yeah come in I
kept at you like you want anything you
do anything I caught you in Denver this
is 10 years ago that's exactly right two
years ago exactly anyway
Bubba didn't get it I'm so heartbroken
for nothing about that but but you're
not got so much crying man I started
crying I was so heartbroken for you and
then boom dude 22 episodes but remember
how resigned I was I was like I just
went about my day because that's the way
it always enjoyed me you know that but
you pretended you're like this dude I
don't I'm not looking at my phone I
think you're annoying me
act like you care cuz you do care you
can't help but care I get plus you can't
help but care whenever you try for
anything in life and you know the one
thing that I always see is like it's
really hard to go for something because
then you have to admit that you really
want it and then you have to admit that
you might fail and you are gonna fail
and that's what's so hard about it like
admitting what you want everyone sees it
though - in the business where
everyone's gonna see your failure I know
it's like fitting and picked up for the
pilot ones like just Brian's pilot
didn't get picked up like yeah dude yeah
you don't see it it didn't get picked up
yeah so we all know yeah yeah and this
whole business that we're in is if
you're not if you're not trying if
you're not going for it you're gonna be
surpassed by people that are like
there's no way to not take all of it
personally in acting and it's it's it's
no joke that CrossFit is no joke man is
so [ __ ] hard it's not it's not to
take anything away from what the hell
it's so hard it's crazy how like how
many people are into it huh I don't yeah
it's it's really it is amazing stuff to
watch because when they do the fittest
man or woman on earth they don't know
what they don't even know what the
events are gonna be they're they're
surprised by them you know easy they've
done those events before they don't know
the order but no no they actually
haven't done other they'll change it all
no no you're gonna carry somebody as
opposed to a sandbag there's different
things like
but this is carrying the motion and the
the pole up you said they bought they
yeah that's all they do it's the only do
so much stuff in CrossFit they've done
it before they just don't know the order
but they are without a doubt the fittest
people on earth there's a cross-section
of challenges where you're just like
alright what it what is fittest on earth
though because it's the ability to run
farther carry more weight but it's hard
to say fittest person on earth because
like if they have to do what let's say
like a cam Haines has to do they
couldn't do it but gods can't do what
they do
yeah or if you ask them to do what they
have endurance and power and speed they
have everyone football players don't or
NBA players don't I don't know that NBA
players have the kind of weightlifting
that goes on so but it's more skill it's
also physical but it's also skill it's
very sports specific I'm not saying it
on great shape these guys are doing like
this this is what bothers me to say
they're the fittest on earth is silly
because Christian McCaffrey who plays
two hours every Sunday gets hit is in
phenomenal shape it's just a different
type of shape yeah so there that's the
fittest crossfitter what's you know I'm
saying that's a person I'm gonna freak
out that's all you could buy yeah but
that's yeah yeah I mean I know what
you're saying
it's just different that guy's natural
bring that guy up he's natural that's
not that's that's that's I I don't know
why anybody killed these people aren't
natural when I want them to be on
steroids I got mad at him because they
went bad and I got popped for steroids
but why even ask you a piece of [ __ ]
white like it's like the Olympians a
we're going mad hours you know who cares
but you know the people like with the
Olympia
it doesn't mean it's just it's it
doesn't mean it's not just as hard
doesn't mean it's not impossible be what
it does like it when you see that girl
or if you see the Olympia P although
steroids because there you couldn't what
steroids you still care about their body
so it gives them a reason steroids like
that you still do that to everybody in
the field is doing something and they're
still competing at a high high level and
it's just like Lance Armstrong everybody
who's do exactly that's how he's just
better at it yeah that's right let's do
some current events I gotta go to a
CrossFit gym so this is supposed to be
an optical illusion that all the kids
are talking about
tick tock yeah so Filipino girl younger
Filipino girl she made this famous
apparently and let me know if you guys
notice anything optical illusion about
this does that look like an illusion see
at all
she looks beautiful that's what that
looks like she's very young do it again
the BG 17 I don't know tip-top oh no
she's just using that that lead hand but
does it look like did looks weird to
McGinnis this this thing you said that
she goes through all I could see was her
doing that yes good dude that you magic
oh your magic dark magic nope let me try
again ready they put the music on
oh yeah chicka chicka chicka Bow Oh and
then she all she's gone yeah let me see
it one more time oh she's gone good for
her man why would I give that to you as
it's a get sag if it's a gift